[Music]
[Applause]
Stu Holden the Fox Sports lead analyst
for the FIFA World Cup joining us from
uh Qatar Stu thanks for joining us uh I
know it's a match once they get on to
the uh the pitch but this feels like
there's a little bit more tension that's
around it the Ambiance there how would
you describe it
yeah for sure first of all 510 165 right
that's how I have to announce myself
coming in red hot here from uh Qatar
look there's a lot off the field there's
a lot of history between these two
Nations there's a lot going on off the
field with Iran I think we saw that have
a real effect on their team for the
first game of the tournament they got
thumped by England Six to two the
players didn't sing the national anthem
they turned that around in the second
game I think got that out of their
system and the pressure of you know
representing their Nation during this
time right now they win their second
match and now they're in a position to
advance where they only need a tie today
against the United States and the US
team coming in needing a win so you know
there's a lot at stake I think
considering also as you said what's
going on let alone off the on the field
but I do think that this is a case of
this is all the talk this is all
bubbling over it's creating an energy
between the fans the two Nations but
once that ball is kicked it's 11v11 it's
a soccer ball and you know I I still
fancy the US to use that energy in the
right way actually one of my colleague
quickly Alexi Lalas he said when they
played Iran back in the World Cup he
underestimated actually what the
political tensions and how that really
helped the Iranian team and they didn't
match that so I would assume that this
group group has been briefed on that
where are you right now
I am right outside uh all to Mama's
Stadium it's called it's one of the
eight venues here this is where the U.S
will be playing against Iran in about
what we got two and a half hours until
kickoff here I'll be inside on the call
and uh it's it's crazy there's like a
buzz going on around the stadium and uh
almost just I think me like many fans
and like the players you just want to
get this game started now do they
tailgate over there
no well uh you know I'm sure you saw
that there's designated fan zones where
you're allowed to drink uh outside of
the stadiums you are not allowed to
drink inside the stadiums there's no
alcohol unless you're in VIP
um you know take that for what it's
worth but it's not quite the same
culture although one of the best things
of a World Cup though really is all the
you know these melting pots of all the
different fans partying and bongo drums
and all the rest of it uh the pressure
on the United States is what if you
could measure it
this generation of players I think has
been built up as one of our most
exciting yet but yet no matter what
happened the last four years no matter
the fact that we're the second youngest
team in the tournament this team will be
judged on what happens tonight fair or
not fair U.S teams are judged at a World
Cup not if you win these domestic
competitions this is when the eyes of
our nation comes and watches soccer like
we become soccer Nations for small
moments that's during the World Cup I
mean we had on Black Friday us England
our highest watch men's game ever on
national TV almost 19 million viewers we
peaked at this is when people watch and
this is where you bring people into our
soccer tent and we as Americans we're
pretty damn good at sports we're great
at the NFL basketball baseball we're not
the best in soccer and I think there's
an expectation that we start to catch up
if we can't beat Iran in a game that's a
one and done to advance to the round of
16 I think it's going to once again send
the message the message that we're still
a little ways off here did you play
against Mass C or Ronaldo
I did yeah uh Messi I I tried to get a
piece of his shirt at any time in the
game unreal man uh you know that for me
is one that I'll tell my kids I hope
they their kids tell their grandkids
like that that to me is the best player
to have ever played the game I don't
know what you think watching him Dan I
mean like his just skill set and how
he's so diminutive but yet just so the
guy delivers I would love to see him
lift his first World Cup here in Qatar
but how do you explain his greatness if
I look at him and and we have athletes
in all different sports where you go it
defies logic because there's there's
nothing that is impressive when you see
Messi but then you see what he does when
he's on a soccer field how do you
explain it
yeah he he just says that Supernatural
ability think about some of the best
athletes that we have had in our history
and Michael Jordan is a guy right that
he carries that presence when you
stepped on a field with him or stepped
on a court with Jordan I I Steve Nash is
a good one of my buddies and he talked
about you know when I when I say who was
better LeBron or Michael Jordan and he
just said Jordan carried this Aura when
he was on the court that you you knew he
was always capable of delivering the big
time play and we continually ask that of
Messi right and Messi with his backs
against the wall the other night they
Argentina needed a win to stay in the
tournament who scores the goal it's
messy he has one chances
it's one shot he he just has that that
ability no matter what the pressure
tight spaces he can always deliver and
continues to carry that pressure and
make it seem like it's nothing so he's
he's a goat man just it's just so
impressive uh Ronaldo did you play
against him
I I did not
um you know Ronaldo is I guess such a
big figure like Messi but so different
right I just think they're contrasting
in the way if you looked at the two of
them in the room and I think you said
hey who's who's the better athlete
everybody would say it's Ronaldo right
like Ronaldo is built like a figurine
he's like a sculpture he is two percent
body fat he's handsome he's you know
he's powerfully strong both feet he's he
can jump out of the building
um I have a lot of respect for Ronaldo
I'm still on the messy team and I know
you know people are normally in one camp
or another I think just I I like Messi
and that he can fit into any team I
think Ronaldo uh has to play in a
specific type of team to be successful
I'll uh leave you with this the Saudis
got rolls royces after beating Argentina
is that true
yeah that is true yeah
uh do other kinds of Saudis the Saudis
got Rolls-Royce I actually just heard
that um
Christian pulisic gave all of his
teammates a Cartier watch uh ahead of
this tournament
has kind of you know sometimes the star
player on the team does that and he made
a point of saying to the guys like this
is a this is a special thing I'm giving
my teammates this and we're gonna do
this together Greg burhalter the coach
gave him Tiffany bracelets I I know
what's the equivalent for the US guys
right like if we beat Iran or we make a
run for the quarter finals what are we
giving these guys like let's let's name
it now let's go let's go out there and
get a sponsor like is an All-American
Ford pickup truck maybe uh maybe I could
talk Tesla yeah my well I'm sponsored by
Mercedes maybe we could uh you know we
could hook them up it's unlike the
Saudis where they're giving out a
Rolls-Royce to you pretty good hey um
Stu thanks for joining us we appreciate
it and uh have fun
Dan appreciate it man that's uh Stu
Holden the Fox Sports lead analyst for
uh the World Cup on the call for the
must win match the Men's National Team
versus Iran live coverage starts at one
Eastern on Fox and right up to uh
kickoff at two Eastern